loves everybody if you piss off your mom
it's like pissing off mother teresa um
no he
he oh my god that was just a very like
toxic i guess like we would break up all
the time like we broke he broke up with
me
twice
and then like would want to get back
with me like the next day and i would i
would just like he's like getting guys
why do guys what would you describe that
guy as and then like
the this last time is the first time i
broke up with him
yeah and you actually like stuck to it
yeah
yeah it's hard but he literally broke up
with me like three times but did you
actually think he was dumping you or
he's trying to do it for attention um
[Music]
what do you think no i thought it was
real every time i like i'm i'm never
used to why aren't you emotional well i
just would never think you would dump
someone for attention or just for a day
like that was new to me i don't know
what they could have cheated justifies
it not saying that like don't be sad who
cares no i
i will you gotta have that mindset girl
i'm gonna get it into you who cares
who cares well at this point like i
really right yeah and honestly those
type of men like the one that i was
showing you on the google
they needed attention and some people
just can't give that to them because
they can't give it to themselves like
it's never full it's not your fault you
could have been a horrible match for him
you could have well i'm anxious so i
think that's pretty bad with fearful
avoidance because we we have like a
tendency to people please and like give
up all our boundaries pretty easily and
that's all that's like that's what i
learned in this last relationship is
that i
give up i'm really easy to control which
can be a good thing and a bad thing like
i bosses always like me because i'm
really easy like i'll give up control
easily i don't really care what we do or
like
but like the wrong person getting all
that control like
they'll take advantage when you submit
to the wrong man yeah but i'm very much
i'm very much like i feel like you have
good boundaries
oh no i didn't not in that relationship
i stopped doing everything i liked doing
like i stopped playing guitar i stopped
seeing my friends i stopped seeing my
family because i was just so like
consumed in it now when you say that was
it because he didn't want you to go were
they bad influences or did you have like
an apathy you didn't want to play
anymore like you were depressed oh no it
was more like
draining
your face
it was more like um
he just
i you know i still care about him so i'm
trying to like no that's fine just talk
[ __ ] we don't know
but it looks worse like honestly no no i
like he's not a bad person and i really
no no he's not he's not he's not a bad
person
um
i don't know going on social media and
talking [ __ ] about your breakup didn't
you do that or am i
am i thinking that
yeah that's why i thought you don't have
to answer no but he he um that's
attention
he what am i thinking he basically like
sucked the life out of him
i don't want to say suck the life out of
me it's more like how did i put it
he just
he he was a social media influencer so
he just wanted he didn't really do much
like
it was weird to see someone make so much
money doing nothing
so he just wanted to hang out big
he posted a video he got a million
followers in a day what did he post an
angry reaction like
so you got a million followers in a day
so he didn't you know does he look funny
when he's like great
when what does he look funny when he's
angry that's embarrassing
you should be scared enough no no it was
but he um
you saw but yeah so he just required
like so much of my time and just always
wanted to like hang out that i
instead of you know sticking to a
boundary which isn't necessarily his
fault you know because i agreed to it
and everything that i did i agreed to
but i just realized like
at the end of the year like i haven't
i've barely seen my family this year
even though i'm living at home i barely
i don't have any friends left like i
don't play guitar i don't sing anymore i
don't do anything that i did a year ago
and you realize that like damn yeah
thanks a lot i was like and so when i
got to england like i started
getting kind of like myself back because
he wasn't around so i started playing
guitar again and like being more
consistent on youtube and even like all
the stuff killing it yeah
very consistent guys go follow her
desperately
but when that happened like
i don't know if that makes sense like
then i just started like to realize like
we were arguing all the time when you
find your piece it's like oh [ __ ] yeah
and we were and it's just why they keep
you isolated yeah well and it doesn't
mean like i still miss him you know but
it's just like
i
was he an alpha
an alpha that's what people are saying
he was an alpha i don't think so to be
quite honest with you i think he
i would not say he was
um there's nothing more girly than being
like
don't want to say social media
influencer but like
that combined with the need for
you to be with him 24 7. to me that
gives me weird vibes he had a snapchat
kid
he actually didn't have snap um but i
think it was like you know of true
dude i think it's it's kind of like a
mix like i could see alpha and beta
traits in him to be honest i wouldn't
give him like one or the other yeah
yeah people were sick i think in a
relationship like you're bound to see a
guy's like alpha and beta side at some
point
if they're allowed you
so here's the thing
i know people aren't religious
and that's okay but i do have followers
that are
in the bible somewhere i couldn't quote
it for you but it says something like we
know men need to be respected and women
need to be loved
so which one comes first the man has to
show the love and then the woman
respects you in the bible so the fact
that do you follow me right now
so the fact that you weren't
willingly
respect like you would
love to respect the right guy so the
fact that you didn't
it's like you were going through the
motions
because that's what you thought was the
right thing that we're women do though
we suck we get attached sometimes i i
get very attached like if i i feel like
i can genuinely love anybody
like i i genuinely feel like if i
am around someone enough like i can love
anybody people get opportunistic very
incorrectly
how would you define it
love yeah because the fact that you had
to say like you could do it i know what
you were getting at because people like
to say that we can't fall in love
like we are
opportunistic
by nature well i think love at first is
a feeling but it becomes a choice at
some point
what are your parents what kind of
advice do your parents give because i
feel like they're good
yeah um my parents give great advice um
my dad told me
to leave that well i didn't take a lot
of it
um the first time he broke up with me i
think like they told me to like
he's like why would you he asked me if i
was um if i liked torture my dad he was
like he's interest he's like he keeps
breaking up with you and you keep going
back you could be a mass so kissed dude
he's like do you like torture um
yeah cause it would upset you
yeah um
i'm trying to think
my mom told me to find a guy that loves
you more than you love him which is very
opposite of what the man of sphere says
no it's not no
no in terms of the way men love
that's the way men love
i i think women
it gets a bad rap she's not wrong
women can love you guys let's just be
clear we can love you we can love what
you do for us we can love
it
people think it's not love but here's
the thing the way that you fall in love
with a girl's smile
when you protect us
you stand up for us and do things that
are masculine
we fall in love with you too it's just
different dude like i'm not you're you
talking or breathing sometimes annoys
the [ __ ] out of me
it's different
no i think that like i think i've been
in love twice and i like i would say i
was genuinely in love twice i think i
was in love
never
you don't think you've ever been in love
no i was once i'll give that
kurt pappas
yeah but we
we are like
dude we both have the mo we did at least
have horrible things just going on in
our lives and it just couldn't work
i couldn't support him because i'm
unemotional
i couldn't like he couldn't he could
support me he was better at words but i
didn't want to be talked to so we lived
up he was in another state at the time
but
he's a very uh
what we would call beta
girls can love a beta but he was the guy
every girl wanted so it's weird i don't
know i think girls he was like
i've seen girls very in love with beta
guys i think it's just when a girl gets
too experienced like she's experienced
too many alphas
alphas are overrated yeah um well i
don't
alpha's i don't really i can't say i
really meant that many maybe rolo that's
it
you think she's alpha yes really
percent
i i like him but like don't you two i
just don't like man
i like him but think about it both of us
said we want to marry him and not fm
what's your point that's beta you want
to marry like marry the beta after the
alpha
that doesn't apply okay we can't marry
him mm-hmm so would you [ __ ] him
probably
would would i i think he would
no
it's not really my time
have you met him no dude the way he
moves
trust me is an alpha
okay dude i was like whoa
that's intense
in a very
uh peculiar way unfamiliar very
comforting i liked it good times dude
you talked to him about anything
no he's really smart and i think like
he's a really interesting guy i just
wouldn't when i think alpha would not
think of rolo tomasi i know what you
mean like i get what you're saying but
then i've never met him in person maybe
that would change you should see how the
guys act around him you know he's an
alpha
well i think they respect his word
outside
people that don't know him i'm telling
you dude okay i survived i would i
wouldn't vouch for him that much no i i
believe you he's an alpha now the other
people i'm just kidding no
no actually you know what's crazy like
when i was thinking about um like
boundaries and giving up yeah i he like
because he you know he was homeless when
i first met him so i like moved him into
my parents house so he could get an id i
tell you this story it sounds like a
story i've told no so like basically he
was he was super hit a lot of money but
he was homeless and when i met him like
i remember thinking i never met a guy
that um
like had such a lack of almost like
parents like i felt really bad because
he had no proof that he
existed that's a hard
thing he lost like everything but his
birth certificate that was all he had
but he couldn't get an id because he
didn't have an address i talked about
this so even
even if he didn't even if he had like
the money where would you mail it to
yeah and so my parents put them like on
our lease oh so that was how like and
they like moved him in for like he lived
with us for like a month
that's it
well then we got an apartment because he
wanted to get an apartment before but
gotcha gotcha so he i get it so he lived
up i guess i have lived with a guy
technically but i don't know i don't
really count that that's in my parents
um and plus like we had separate rooms
but um good
i don't know if that makes sense
but i was just thinking like that was so
crazy i literally like met him and like
then moved him basically into my parents
house and look at where you guys are at
now
what do you mean you're not together
yeah so
makes me wonder
if subconsciously
the reason that you're not together is
because although he makes more money
he just doesn't move in the right frame
obviously i feel like we've established
that
i'm just ripping onto this guy i know
nothing about
no you've been so sweet about it but i
think
you're being too nice don't be nice
because he
like it wasn't like it was all bad you
know like there's times where he took me
to an nba finals game he took me like
there's a lot of like really nice dates
he took me on and like trips like i
can't
is that why you love him
no
no no what do you love him well name
stuff that you love him for other than
the cool [ __ ] i just i i walked you into
that don't worry you're fine
he's he's the funniest person i've ever
met like genuinely he's so funny
is he oh yeah he's so funny
okay what else name five things what
else um he's very creative
um and
you like creative because you're
creative right okay um very high energy
i really like high energy people that's
like you yes i mean we like people that
are like ourselves we do i think so i
think that's true so but everything that
you listed had to do with
things that could benefit you
do you think it benefits me
i'm being creative creative benefits
because you guys are kind of in the same
that's not a bad thing i think that gets
so misconception i don't think it's bad
i would love to date somebody in the
same uh yeah
you're trying to right
i am i'm married i'm just kidding no i'm
not trying i'm i'm not i'm not a ghost
the guy on the phone no
kevin ah
he lives in connecticut okay
we'll see
he's he's like you should do a virtual
date like um live that'd be funny like
on instagram i just don't know those
i wanna
he parents me on camera every time i
love it he was also very like comforting
i would say like he was very
like what do you want when he
was like nice he was like really nice
and very like kind
mm-hmm that's a good thing yeah
most people are
yeah
yeah i don't know i don't know what you
would say that wouldn't be i know
that's my point is there's nothing wrong
with it yeah every people are going to
spew it but i just want to do it before
them because if i do it then it's better
trust me no no i mean it's funny i don't
want a man's it's like i'm not saying
but it's like i when i would think or
you ask a guy what do you like about her
and they always hesitate because the
only thing they can come up with is what
she looks like
we both suck i'm not saying neither is
better
but
when you ask a guy how he fell in love
with somebody it's usually like she had
a really weird laugh
no that's not
not it actually but it's like the way
she smiled when she was prepping the
pizza
and laughed at my joke like they fall in
love with that poetic [ __ ] and you would
think that we do but no we felt safe to
some capacity